welcome last year's versatile Academy
Award winners Matt Damon and Ben Affleck
in our movies costume drama shows us the
world as it was romantic drama the world
as it could be and documentaries the
world as it is if you're shopping for a
documentary film you have your choice of
two sizes feature-length or short
subject excuse me
the only difference is of course that
one is longer than the other for best
achievement in short subjects I was
distracted the three nominees are the
personals improvisation zon romance in
the golden years Kiko EB
a place in the land Charles Guggenheim
sunrise over Tiananmen Square shree
Boeing and Donald McWilliams and the
Oscar goes to the personals
improvisation zon romance in the golden
years
once proud Miss Japan Grand Prix this is
the first Academy Award for a Kato Eevee
thank you
food thought a girl from Japan can make
a movie about Jewish senior citizens and
actually receive the sword
I'm extremely grateful to Seth Glassman
and my wonderful wonderful teen years in
my movie
and extra special special thanks to
Sheila Nevins of HBO and my my editor of
Milton Ginsberg food here up there
somewhere and my cell jogger from my co
filmmaker my husband Greg pack and I
also like to thank the Academy for
recognizing the short documentary films
and I hope that you will continue to do
so and you finally my mother for letting
me come to the United States so I could
follow my dream to become a filmmaker
thank you
there are five films nominated for
documentary feature and if it were up to
me every single one of them would win oh
and the nominees are dance maker Matthew
Diamond and Jerry Kupfer
the farm Angola USA Jonathan stack and
Lisgar vez the last days James mall and
pen Lipper Lenny Bruce swear to tell the
truth
Robert PYT regret to inform Barbara
Santa born and Janet Cole and the Oscar
goes to the last days
this is the first Oscar for James mol
and Ken Lipper
and for Steven Spielberg survivors of
the show of visual history foundation
thank you on behalf of the producer of
the film June Beeler who I share this
honor with and the other producer of the
film Ken Lipper and everybody involved
with the making of the last days we want
to thank the five amazing show of
survivors who shared their truly
inspirational lives with us we also want
to thank Evelyn Lipper and Marie Stine
and of course October films and good
machine for getting this film seen
around the world and last but not least
certainly but not least our executive
producer Steven Spielberg for his for
his strength of character and his vision
in establishing the Shoah foundation
videotaping more than 50,000 survivor
testimonies all over the world and
insuring through those testimonies and
through this film that survivors will
have a voice for generations to come
thank you
two men who are no strangers to the
Academy Awards Martin Scorsese and
Robert De Niro